hi christina hi how are you i'm good
thank you how are you i am doing very
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this it's uh
certainly pretty heavy to watch and i
would imagine uh pretty heavy to explore
as an actor too
totally yeah it's not light watching um
not at all not in the slightest we're
also just dealing with uh there's a lot
of
of heavy material
um
which we largely pulled from the book so
we didn't really have a choice in the
matter
well when this project came your way
what most excited you about the
opportunity to do it and what were you
most scared
about um when it first came around
the first thing that i noticed actually
was just the fact that it was set in the
pacific northwest and i'm from seattle
and telling stories that are like
central to that part of the country was
exciting for me and then i read it and
um
molly's writing was so engaging and
fresh and um
had such a unique point of view that it
just immediately drew me in um
and
also you know i've worked with margaret
a few times now she's incredibly
talented and so that was exciting
and um
it was
it was
the challenge was exciting it was
definitely a departure from any dif from
any role that i've played before um and
so that
was an exciting opportunity but also the
scariest thing about it you know was
stepping outside of my comfort zone and
um
playing
kind of the villain
yeah i mean really to himself more than
anyone else totally yeah sean is his own
worst enemy uh along with
sort of everyone else's but
yeah he's as that character has a lot of
demons that he's wrestling with and
is kind of negotiating with over the
course of the show
um
and you know
he's ultimately
is somewhat redeems himself at the end
but
it's a rocky road to get there
between
simon and a teacher and now this i mean
you've definitely been playing some very
different characters from each other
what have you learned about yourself as
an actor from doing some of the very
different recent projects that you've
done
um i mean i've learned that
um
i
i like doing these different
types of roles where it's not um
[Music]
it's it's not the same thing over and
over and um
i think that uh
yeah just
the older i get the the more um
i
have been able to try at least to take
more agency kind of over
my own
choices and projects um and
trying to like
um
be
yeah there as
as um
specific and and
uh
intentional as possible uh what i'm
picking um or have the opportunity to do
and uh yeah i've learned that like
um
you sometimes just the stuff that scares
you is the stuff that
is the thing that more often than not
will
um
that you'll be most proud of at the end
of the day or that will kind of garner
the most attention
um and just not being
not letting yourself get in your own way
in terms of
falling too much into a comfort zone or
a complacency try to make sure that
you're always
going a little bit further into the deep
end you know
this character
is an alcoholic he's in a toxic
relationship we see that so much of his
behavior is rooted in his family even
though that's not an excuse for him
hurting other people
how did you approach getting inside of
the mindset of this character were there
things that
helped you in understanding those issues
with addiction and abuse for him
yeah i um
i mean the first sort of reference point
was the book but stephanie
wrote that book about her life and very
much
relegated the chara different character
in the book but the character the k the
same character i was playing in the show
to sort of the sidelines you don't get
to know much about him
um
and
beyond that i felt like
i
knew some people in my life who had
similar issues as sean and
um
sort of saw
the way that they could lash out there
were
um
there was one family friend in
particular in seattle who i knew that
was like
had a heart of gold and like would give
you the shirt off his back but then also
just
really struggled in certain areas of his
life um and could not get out from
underneath that
uh and i think
sean um
is
an example of somebody who
[Music]
allows himself to just kind of fall
victim to his own circumstance
and he's trying um but like like you
mentioned he has
a lot of trauma in his past with his
family and um
you know that
has gradually kind of gotten passed down
i think to him
and so he copes
in the only way that he knows how and
the way that he was modeled his you know
behavior was modeled which is alcohol
drugs
um
in order to kind of
ease some of that trauma and pain of his
past and yeah it and he loses control of
it uh multiple times throughout the the
um throughout the series
um
and it was just such a well-written
character too
molly
kind of spelled it all out on the page
and so
you know it made my job a lot easier
yeah that definitely helps
yeah well how do you feel about where
things end up for him as someone who
lived with him for as long as you did do
you wish things could have been
different for him do you hope that maybe
somewhere down the road he gets himself
together more
yeah i mean absolutely i hope that sean
you know is able to get sober and sort
of
tackle his demons and
be an active part of his daughter's life
and um
you know hopefully
be able to
forgive himself and um
you know
ask for forgiveness for people around
him for his actions and move forward
with his life i think um
where you see him at the end is
definitely
a low point but it's also
uh i think he has kind of a moment of
clarity and
does the right thing in letting his
daughter
you know
go on to hopefully have a better life
than he did so it's sort of this last
act of like kindness that he ends it on
and hopefully
he is able to
yeah get his life together after that
but who knows
did you have a favorite scene to shoot
were these all challenging difficult
scenes or were there
scenes that felt lighter that you
actually had a little fun with doing
um i really enjoyed uh there's a few
different uh
moments throughout the show that i
actually had a lot of fun shooting
there's the birthday party sequence
um when all of the
al alex hosts maddie's birthday party at
her new house yeah just the way it was
shot was really fun it allowed us a lot
of freedom it was just a lot of kind of
roving camera stuff that there wasn't
necessarily blocking you kind of just
went where it felt natural and they
would
follow you
that was really fun
a lot of the um
i mean a lot of the uh sets and like the
trailer for example even though it was
kind of a dark space
it was fun because it was a practical
set it was just a single wide and you
could have free reign to go and open a
drawer and find
utensils and like everything was sort of
just set up
and created this very
whole world to play and that's really
just credit to the production designer
renee and art department
and uh so those those scenes were always
really fun like either
in the trailer or um in any kind of
ensemble setting where it felt like
very free you just felt very free to do
what you wanted um
uh so i'd say those are probably
probably my favorite
yeah i mean this definitely felt like
something where everybody had to be all
in and that you know even when there are
things that were difficult to do you
just sort of had to be fully
in doing them totally yeah um it was it
was a group effort and everybody
was yeah in it 100
um
and you it was infectious for sure we
kind of felt that
uh
as we went along and it made it a fun
environment it's fun to come to work too
well thank you for talking to me about
it it is definitely heavy to watch but
also still hopeful so i i appreciate you
talking to me about it of course yeah
thanks for the time christina